hey there thought it'd be a great idea
to come out here today and do real for
honor simulator this shield right here
things going to pay dividends Ren
doesn't have one he thinks he can get
away with just his reach with that
broadsword right how do these rigs work
if you've seen our previous two FTD
videos you know it's up but what's
happening is that there's an SPD camera
here first person view sending a signal
directly from the camera to these
goggles that I'm wearing what you're
seeing right now is the exact image that
is going on in my eyeballs right now hey
Jake what are the rules for the sword
fighting game the rules are simple don't
get hit don't get eliminated three two
one
game on and if you get hit in any of the
limbs you just lose that limb one thing
I'm concerned about is that Ren spends a
lot more time in these FPV rigs than I
do
his likelihood of understanding depth
perceptions is a lot higher than mine in
2d so the zero depth perception I'm not
going to be able to see how far away
Jake is he cuts off one of my limbs I'm
gonna have a lot of trouble because
trying to move in these are hard enough
without a limb you're pretty much
screwed
because I think I just click on rent pan
my field was definitely a good pick here
although I didn't take it field he got
me hard whoa
I've defeated Renly for thousands and
now I paid the more powerful Viking a
punt with battle axes to defeat his axis
I chose one of my own Carmichael the
Viking you gotta watch out for that guy
he's got a he's got a streak of
lightning in his foot they have this
crazy screen I've only heard legend up
from other people that have been in
battles with them thankfully God of War
has blessed me with this giant battle ax
this thing's got a ton of reach so I can
swing just pretty much wildly with
enough consistency I'll probably hit it
problem is you got a lot of time in
between swings on this and if at any
point he sees an open opportunity I'm
dead
[Music]
what real time you need to learn some
nobility my lack can't be a champion
watching killed my twin brother
Carmichael but I'm gone Michael I will
kill this son of a [ __ ] one thing you
can't do in fur honor is ride on a halo
Ford hopper wheel you will single handed
weapons green earth these things are
hard enough to ride as it is not to
mention when you can't see you have no
perspective of balance I'm worried that
getting so close coming it's going to be
literally to each other and fall yeah I
probably just fall on my ass really
to run came on just like your brother I
will take you down
Oh didn't bless me with a chariot with
that ah
mace you can get back on the other word
right
I think we should do that again because
I think we'll get each other in the face
the exact same time any different
strategies ah gonna try some blocking
this time
come on to me - rah rah rah
- you were rolling back we came back on
gate coming in for the kill
see you know once I get through bar
Michael that will be the end of the
bloodlines there'll be no more claim to
the king tips going to get to this one
last guy
they quit The Flaming River
undefeated brother
my name is Carmichael what is happening
guys
you killed my two oldest brother you
will hurt your whole house from here
swine let me die he dies
god
dose baby purge [ __ ] Michael more like
nor Michael I'll kill your whole house
all the way we get to czar michael
carmichael good game good game ran good
game good game
thank you for hooking up the rigs I'm
sad that Renly 4000 was defeated snow
early on but his legend was gone in his
armor what time is it coming you killed
my king joshey dead friendship
unstoppable is right here's the very
power of Duke this power